let's give it up for pay all pay all cut
Kanaka and how so tell us how to make
everybody get up it's time to slam now
we got a real Jam going down welcome to
the Space Jam a pseudo chance through
your dance at the Space Jam
[Applause]
[Music]
hello everyone hi everyone I'm Kyle
Kodaka the founder and executive
chairman of classpath I hear we have
some fans in the audience whoo love
Sam's story as well and so for those of
you not familiar with lap pads it's a
monthly Fitness membership program that
lets you take classes at different
studios and gyms you can go to a Sam's
flat spin class yoga class whenever you
want to and the journey of class laughs
which I'm very excited to share with you
guys today have been long and winding
like most artists are and instead of
just telling you guys all about the
successes and failures I'm going to
focus on one important thing that really
led to the success of our company and
that was making hard decisions we all
faced them in our lives and in our
companies and they're challenging but I
will tell you and I hope from the
stories I tell you today that you can
make through them make it through them
and get to the other side so let's start
my parents came here in the 70s from
India and the most important things for
them was making sure my sister and I got
a good education and had a good career
so I went to MIT and I worked at Bain
but my true passion alight as you can
see here with Indian dance so I started
dancing when I was 3 years old
and it became the place where I belonged
it was my heart my passion and it always
made me feel centered so three years
into consulting at Bain most of my
friends were going off to business
school it just didn't feel like the
right decision for me at the time I
wanted to pursue dance and so that was
the first hard decision I had to make in
my life
I didn't follow the path of many others
and I took a job in the music industry
and while that was challenging at the
time it actually opened up an amazing
opportunity for me
I built my first startup and it was a
dance company I got together the best
dancers I knew in New York City and we
started practicing and performing every
weekend and every night we performed all
around the nation amazing venues like
Alvin Ailey and Lincoln Center we even
ended up on the cover of the art section
of the New York Times I was having the
time of my life I was in my 20s I spent
all my time either at work or dancing
but three years in I was at another
crossroads this wasn't going to be
sustainable and I also didn't know what
I was going to do with my career luckily
enough at that time I went to go visit
one of my friends in San Francisco and I
met all these entrepreneurs and in New
York City about six years ago there
weren't many and so I saw all these
people building these amazing apps and
products and it was amazing that they
were doing it on their own terms
I knew how driven I was I also knew how
creative I was and I thought I should
give that a chance but I needed to think
of an idea
so I actually gave myself two weeks to
think of something 36 hours later I was
sitting at my desk and I was looking for
a ballet class online after being on
Yelp for hours google searching and
having multiple tabs open I was really
frustrated and I didn't even go to class
I kept thinking to myself what if there
was an open table for classes it seemed
to make sense and I knew I had to build
it not just because I wanted to be a
tech entrepreneur but I wanted to
connect people back to their passions I
had fought to keep dancing my life my
entire being through college through my
career and I wanted to help bring that
back to other people
there was one big thing in my way though
my job I don't know how many of you guys
have quit your job before or thought
about it it's not an easy decision my
favorite quote is on the other side of
your greatest lines or greatest fears
lives your greatest life and that's how
this day went down I got to work that
day I told my boss hey I think I'm going
to go pursue some entrepreneurial
endeavor
I wrote an email it's my executive team
and one of them who I've spoken with
maybe a few times in my three years
there decided to call me to his office
he wanted to hear about what I was
building so I went up there and I was a
little nervous I hadn't really gone up
there before and he spent two hours with
me I told him about what I was building
and I walked out of that office that day
with a $10,000 check and my first
advisor this was the day I quit my job
and so we were off to the races we
started building class tivity which was
the first incarnation of class path it
was an open table for classes and we
were aggregating all this data and all
the schedules from around New York City
we even got into tech stars in York we
were one of 13 companies out of 1,500 to
get in and finally at demo day we
launched our product and this was a year
and a half after we started building it
and that's a really important point
which I'll get to in a second we had a
lot of press we ended up on the cover of
ink magazine and a ton of buzz but I
felt like a fraud inside and here's why
we had no one booking classes so I built
a beautiful website aggregated all this
information but no one was going to
class it was terrible obviously for the
business model but even more so for the
mission I started out the company for I
knew we had to start another product and
try something new so this was our first
pivot instead of sitting behind our desk
this time we started going to the
studios and talking to them about what
they needed we noticed a lot of them
were offering a first class for free and
we decided to package these together and
offer our first product called a
passport what's called the
collectivities passport at the time it
was a $49 offering that let you try ten
classes in your local area one of my
favorite things about this time is after
building a product for a year and a half
and not having it work we were so
scrappy we made our first 20,000
reservations manually for every
reservation that came in we would go and
book it
our selves and then send an email to the
customer we weren't going to build
things that people didn't want class
last Passport did well and in three to
four days we had more reservations in
the search engine but there was a
problem no one was going back to the
studios and we got these classes for
free from our studio owners so we needed
to find a way to fix the business the
one thing we learn at this time was how
much people loved the variety so much so
that they were actually frauding us and
signing up for a product over and over
again when they couldn't we even did a
survey and 95 percent of our members
said they would do this product again if
they could do it and go back to their
favorite studios so all of this was
weaning to a subscription model we
finally launched the subscription model
but to get my team there was not as easy
as and one would think so at this point
I had to before people and in the past
three years I had now asked them to
build two products and we were making
progress with the passport but it wasn't
enough see we had about a metric of 75%
of our customers needing to go back to
our studios to make that relationship
work and only 15% were it was too wide
of a gap and luckily enough my team
believed me and we decided to iterate
one more time so we built class pass
class laughs is a subscription where you
could go back to these classes up to two
times a month when we first started and
it was one of those products that was
immediately viral people just loved it
and they wanted to tell their friends
about it and more than just the
purchases I think what I really felt was
letters from our customers telling me
that they had never looked so forward to
working out and they felt like this
product changed their life I kind of
knew we had hit lightning and that
doesn't happen very often in a company's
history so at that time we had three
products in the market we still had the
search engine we had the passport and we
had slot test for any entrepreneur you
know focus is a really important thing
we weren't focused one of my
entrepreneurs would call me all the time
as they you know pile you need to get
rid of the passport it's like crack to
you guys it will be a chapter in your
one day and at that time I was like no
way such a good product and in hindsight
no one at conferences today knows what
the passport is and so he was right
so we rebranded and became mad fast calm
at that time we actually threw a party
and invited all of our members to it it
was a really fun time in the history of
our company and we knew we had magic but
our investors weren't convinced yet they
didn't know if this was just a New York
City phenomenon so we decided that we
would launch in multiple markets so we
brought classpass to Boston San
Francisco Chicago and we saw the same
adoption in our product I found myself
back on Sand Hill Road to raise more
capital for those of you familiar with
Sand Hill Road is where all of our
favorite VCS are I had been there three
times before many times I came back
empty-handed but this time it was very
different
I had a product that work and people
gave me term sheets I had more money
than I needed
and as exciting as it sounds and someone
you know who'd been building this for
three years I was actually really
overwhelmed I didn't know how to make a
decision on who I was going to build a
future of class path with in three days
so I decided I would make the decision
and go with one of my trusted advisors
for slamet Fritz and I had met earlier
that year via David Tish and when Fritz
and I met he was one of those angel
investors who told me to put away my
slides and just tell me tell him what I
wanted to build it's actually a very
different type of investor most
investors want to doubt you and he
actually told me from my hustle and from
the charts I was showing him on our
growth and he thought I had built the
next generational defining company it
was a conversation I had never had with
an investor and because of that he
became one of my trusted partners and
when he told me he could give me my
twelve million dollars I said let's do
it so it's 12 million dollars of fresh
half roll in the bank and a product our
customers loved and our partners loved
we had to protect it we started seeing
copycats in every city and it was ours
to lose
so we had to move fast we weren't about
launching about eight markets by the end
of that year and instead of launching
eight we wanted to launch 20 and we then
launched ten right after that my team
doubled in size in a matter of 10 days
it was a pretty hard decision to make
but we knew this was art so we started
moving forward we became national and we
also hit our one millionth reservation
yes we were now at 35 million but this
is crazy so we hit our one millionth
reservation we knew that a lot of this
growth was coming from our limited
product it was our product on let people
work out as much as they wanted to as a
founder you put things out there if you
never know how things will end up
playing out in the market and one of the
hardest things for us to ever predict
with usage one of the great things about
our unlimited plan was people started
working out double the amount they used
to but we were paying our studio owners
for every class how is attended so the
business was suffering and we had to do
something about it so this is when we
decided to make our first change to
improve our business and I never wish
this upon any founder is a hard thing to
do but we raise prices by 25 dollars the
hardest thing about that was it didn't
work so we have to go back to the
drawing board and figure out what to do
I knew we have to increase the price of
the plan even more but I still wanted to
make sure we were accessible and
affordable because that is a promise we
made to our members into the world so we
launched a 5 plan in a 10 pack we didn't
know how the market would take them but
luckily enough people love them we
actually in tracked an entire new user
base but we were still having trouble
with our unlimited plan I knew we had to
make a change when I would walk into the
office every day and my employees would
come up to me with new ideas on how we
could restrict usage that's exactly the
opposite of why we started this company
so we finally made the decision to
eliminate our limited product at the end
of last year this is
one of the hardest decisions I've had to
make as a founder I wrote a letter to
all of our members number one thing I
wanted them to know is how hard we tried
and the second thing I wanted them to
know was how much better we were going
to make this experience and luckily
enough they listened and they heard and
they felt it and many of them stayed
with us we actually have a ton of new
plans now that are actually growing even
faster than we were before
so it was great to know that even after
all these nine hard decisions we ended
up having a great business happy
customers and happy studios but there
was one last decision that I had to make
and it was for me personally I started
this company because I'm an artist and I
love creating and building the role of a
founding CEO changes as your company
grows and I wanted to get back to
building so I recently decided to switch
roles with Fritz Fritz is now the CEO of
LastPass and I am the executive chairman
and I am working every day on our new
product brainstorming wireframing
back to the beginning of building the
future of classpath and I couldn't be
more excited we just closed 70 million
dollars of funding which is crazy thank
you
we're in 39 cities globally and
expanding 35 million reservations and we
have a team of over 200 people and my
favorite thing about them is they're
ready for anything we throw at them and
they're ready for the next decision that
we're going to make and so before I
close I leave you all with one question
what's the next hard decision you're
going to make because the best companies
and best people who've made an impact in
the world have all had to make them so I
hope the next time you're faced with one
you decide to say yes thank you
[Applause]
you